اهلا بكم مشاهدي العربيه في ختام جولاته
بالشرق الاوسط قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن انه استمع الى
مخاوف عميقه من الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
بشان استمرار المسار الحالي و خلال مؤتمر
صحفي في القدس على ان الولايات المتحده لا
تقبل باتخاذ خطوات احاديه تجعل حل
الدولتين ابعد مما هو عليه اليوم واكد
لينك انه يجب صياغه رؤيه حل الدولتين
لتحقيق السلام موضحا ان وعشان تريد توسيع
السلام بين اسرائيل والدول الاخرى في
المنطقه في الشان الايراني
امريكا واسرائيل ملتزمه بمنع ايران من
الوصول للسلاح النووي وعرب الوزير
الامريكي عن قلق بلاده من التبادل العسكري
بين ايران وروسيا كما قال بلنكن بحثنا
مواجهه الانشطه الايرانيه المساعده
للاستقرار في المنطقه وقال يكون من
التبادل العسكري بين ايران وروسيا ويجب ان
نتاكد من نزع فتيات للتوتر بين
الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين قام اكد ايضا
بانه يجب ان نخرج من دوامه العنف واستئناف
محادثات السلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين ويجب صياغه رؤيه حل
الدولتين لتحقيق السلام كما اشار بلانكن
باننا نريد توسيع السلام بين اسرائيل
والدول الاخرى في المنطقه
وفي ختام لقائه مع رئيس الفلسطينيه محمود
عباس قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه بلانكين
انه من الضروري وقف حتى تصعيد بشكل عاجل
بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
نحن نرى انه من الضروري اخذوا خطوات سريعه
لتخفيف حده تصعيد والعنف وخلق مساحه تسمح
لنا باستعاده الشعور بالامن للفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين
كما اكد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان كل
الخطوات التي قدمتها الولايات المتحده هي
جزء من طموحها على المدى الطويل
كل الخطوات التي قدمناها هي جزء من طموحنا
على المدى الطويل لتوثيق العلاقات مع
الشعب والسلطه الفلسطينيه وهذا سيسمح لنا
بتحقيق هدفنا في ان يتمتع الفلسطينيون
والاسرائيليون بشكل متساوي من الديمقراطيه
والحريه والكرامه ونحن نؤمن انه يمكننا
تحقيق ذلك من خلال وجود دولتين
من جانبه حمل الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
على الحكومه الاسرائيليه مسؤوليات التصعيد
في الفتره الاخيره لعدم التزامها بحاله
دولتين وشدد عباس على ان الوقف الكامل
للاعمال الاسرائيليه الاحاديه الجانب هي
المدخل الاساسيه لعوده الافق السياسيه
التي تقوي المحل الدوله
[موسيقى]
وعدم الاعتراف بالدور الفلسطينيه
معنى من رام الله مراسل العربيه عبد
الحفيظ جعوان عبد الحفيظ يعني كيف تلقف
الجانب الاسرائيلي التشديد الامريكي على
مبدا حل الدولتين وما هي خلاصه هذه
السياره
بالنسبه للجانب الاسرائيلي يعني وان لم
يبدو ترحيبا في موضوع حل الدولتين نعم
بالنسبه للجانب الاسرائيل نعم بالنسبه
للجانب الفلسطيني اااه ببرود كبير للحقيقه
تلقوا الوعود الامريكيه في موضوع حل
للدولتين وفقا مصادرنا فان الجانب اللي في
الفلسطيني سلم اسرائيل وثيقه من اثنين سلم
عفوا وثيقه مثنى عشر بندا وطلبوا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان تلتزم بها مقابل ان تلتزم
همم السلطه الفلسطينيه او ان تسعى لتوفير
او يعني استثباب الامن في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وان تعود الى طاوله المفاوضات
البنود ترتبط اساسا بالخطوات احاديه
الجانب التي اتخذتها اسرائيل منذ بدايه
منذ هذه الحكومه الجديده وتحديدا الموضوع
اقتحامات المدن موضوع بناء المستوطنات
موضوع القدس وال- همم الثوابت التاريخيه
والدينيه فيها موضوع هدم المنازل ايضا
العق الاخيره التي تخص ااه موضوع مصادره
اموال السلطه الفلسطينيه وغيرها من البنود
التي يعني طرحها الجانب الفلسطيني على
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي وقال هذه البنود
اذا التزمت بها اسرائيل نحن مستعدون فورا
للعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات الجانب
الامريكي قدم عده عودات الجانب الفلسطيني
ااه تحديدا موضوع الالتزام الاداره
الامريكيه بخيار حل الدولتين ايضا بعض
الامور الاجرائيه مثل مثلا 50 مليون دولار
كمساعده للسلطه الوطنيه الفلسطينيه وايضا
همم الدعوه السعي اللي همم خدمه الفور جي
في الفلسطينيين وغيرها من الامور ولكن
بشكل عام وفق لقاءاتنا مع قيادات فلسطينيه
بعد انتهاء هذا اللقاء يقولون هذه وعود
قدمتها الاداره الامريكيه اداره منذ ان
اتت الى الحكم قبل نحو عامين ولكن لم نرى
ولا نرى اي شيء على الارض حتى يعني قبل ان
تاتي هذه الاداره قال هم وعدونا في موضوع
فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس الشرقيه
ولم يحدث فتح مكاتب منظمه التحرير في
واشنطن ولم يحدث ااا الضغط على الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لوقف مشاريع استطانيه كبرى
ولم يحدث وبالتالي هناك يعني سقف التوقعات
منخفض بشكل عام ولكن الجو العام لدى
السلطه الفلسطينيه افضل مما سبق لانه يعني
هناك زياره بلنكن زياره مستشار الامن
القومي مدير الاستخبارات الامريكيه
السياسيه كلهم اتوا الى رام الله واجتمعوا
مع الرئيس الفلسطيني وبالتالي هذه القضيه
التي كانت مع اداره همم ترامب انتهت والان
هناك علاقات مع الاداره الامريكيه على امل
ان تكون الاداره الامريكيه جاده فيما تحدث
عنه وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بشان الرؤيه
المستقبليه رؤيه حل الدوليتين شكرا لك عبد
الحفيظ جوان مراسل العربيه حدثتنا من رام
الله